factor 4y squared plus 4y minus 15 so we
don't have a leading coefficient of one
here and it also doesn't look like we
can factor out a four since fifteen is
not divisible by four so we're going to
try to do is factor this by grouping and
the factor by grouping we want to look
for two numbers whose product is equal
to the product of four and negative 15
we explain it in other videos how that
why this will work but let's just look
for those two numbers so the product is
going to be equal to four times negative
15 four times negative 15 which is
negative 60 and there's some there some
needs to be equal to this 4 right over
here so a plus B has got to be equal to
4 and if we can figure out an a and B to
satisfy this so we can break up this 4y
into an a y plus a B Y and then we can
factor by grouping
now the first clue here is that the
product of the numbers is negative so
that means that a and B must have
different signs
they must have different signs and since
a plus B is equal to 4 we know that the
and I want you to think about this a
little bit we know that the difference
of their absolute values must be equal
to 4 let me just make that concrete that
little statement I just told you if I
were to say well let's just say that I
have and let's ignore this for a second
let me just take two simple numbers if I
have negative 2 times 3 those 2 the
product is going to be equal to negative
6 and then there's some negative 2 plus
3 is equal to 1 notice their product is
negative so they had to have different
signs and their sum is 1 and they have
different signs and 1 is also the
difference of their absolute values the
difference between the absolute value of
3 and the absolute value of 2 is 1
that's what I'm talking about so this
gives us a clue of essentially how far
apart are the absolute values of the
number so let's think about all of the
factors of 60 and then remind ourselves
that they have we're looking for numbers
that are 4 apart one has to be positive
that numbers whose absolute values are 4
apart one has to be positive and one has
to
b-negative so the factors of 60 you
could do 1 and 60 you could do 2 and 30
I'm going to run out of space doing it
this way let me write it as a column so
you have 1 and 60 you have 2 and 30 you
have 3 and you have 3 and 20 you have 4
and 15 you have 5 and 12 you have 6 and
10 this looks pretty tantalizing since
these are 4 apart and then that looks
like we are about done 7 doesn't go into
it 8 doesn't go into it 9 doesn't go
into it we're done now already we
already talked about the difference of
the numbers have the absolute value of
the difference has to be 4 so 6 and 10
looks pretty tempting but let's just go
through all of these numbers over here
so the possible sums here if we make one
positive and 60 negative then there's
going to be a negative 59 remember I'm
making sure that we have different signs
and this is positive this could be
positive or negative and this is
negative or positive I wrote it upside
down here so that their signs are
different so it's either going to be
negative 59 if this is positive and this
is negative or it's going to be positive
69 if this is positive and this is
negative so it's negative or positive 59
and I should say this right over here is
going to be is going to be negative or
positive 28 you see the absolute value
of the difference of the absolute values
of these numbers the difference of the
absolute values of these numbers keeps
showing up now we know that we want to
go to 4 so let's just cut to the chase
and go to 6 and 10 if we take positive
let's see and we want there and we want
them to add up to a positive 4 so the
larger number should be positive so if
we take positive 10 and negative 6 their
sum is definitely going to be equal to 4
and positive 10 times negative 6 is
negative 60 so let's break it up like
that so what we can do is break up the 4
as the sum break up the 4y as the sum of
a negative 6y and a 10 Y so let's do
that so for y I'm going to write as I am
going to write as negative 6y plus 10y
if you add these two together clearly
you get 4
why and then we have the rest of the
problem here we have the 4 y squared
minus 15 now we're ready to factor by
grouping let's group these first two
terms and we can because they have
common factors here they're both
divisible by 2 and Y and then we're
going to group these two guys both of
them are divisible by 5 so if we factor
this first one over here let's factor
out a let's factor out a 2 y over here 2
y 4 y squared divided by 2 y is just
gives us a 2y and then negative 6y
divided by 2y is negative 3 right Y
divided by Y is 1 negative 6 divided by
2 is negative 3 then let's factor this
guy over here you can factor out a 5 so
this is plus 5 times 2y minus 3 and now
lucky for us we can factor out a 2 y
minus 3 we can factor out a 2 y minus 3
so you have 2y minus 3 times x 2 y plus
5 times 2y plus 5 and we are done